[Music]
censorship has always been used by those
in power to stifle the voices of those
who are criticizing them and seeking to
bring about some kind of law reform so
it's not surprising that any
authoritarian regime today and
throughout history has always stifled
protesting voices has always exercised
censorship including over the arts and
culture as well as politics so Nazi
Germany fascist Italy today the Soviet
Union and Turkey and a whole range of
authoritarian countries Saudi Arabia
springs to mind have all exercised
censorship as a way of maintaining the
power of those who hold it and of
preventing reform and spreading of human
rights and and also flirting the pursuit
of truth in realms of science and other
fields of human endeavor
I think the flipside to the question of
what is so dangerous about censorship is
what is so positive about free speech
because we lose the positive potential
of free speech through censorship and
freedom of speech is as great Supreme
Court justices in the United States have
recognized the essence of individual
liberty freedom of thought is cannot
really be exercised unless you have
freedom of speech so it's a way of
forming your ideas forming your own
identity communicating with other people
to forge bonds of friendship bonds of
community freedom of speech is used to
join together with others to amplify our
messages so that we can have more of an
impact and bringing about whatever
changes or
reforms we'd like to see happen in
society freedom of speech is essential
for petitioning the government lobbying
trying to persuade those we elect and
hold accountable to us to adopt certain
policies or reject certain policies a
freedom of speech is also essential for
the pursuit of truth as as somebody once
said every great truth began as a
blasphemy
so if government well had the power to
censor as it has in the past it has
thwarted advances in all kinds of
scientific and social scientific fields
art censorship has been used to stifle
expression that has been important not
only for the individual artist herself
or himself but also for those who are
deprived then of the opportunity to
enjoy the and be inspired and
enlightened by creativity so you know I
think I I definitely agree with the
Supreme Court when it said that freedom
of speech really is the bedrock of every
other right and really almost everything
positive in our society could not be
achieved without that essential bedrock
there is absolutely no doubt that speech
can do an infinite amount of harm as
well as an infinite amount of good the
reason why censorship is bad is
precisely because speech is so powerful
and with that power we human beings can
exert it either to great good or to
great ill now the question is what does
more harm trusting our fellow citizens
on the whole to minimize the adverse
impact adverse potential impact of
speech or trusting
government to pick and choose which
potentially dangerous harmful speech
should be censored what we've seen
throughout history and around the world
not surprisingly is whoever exercises
censorship power doesn't in a way to
perpetuate their own power and to
disproportionately silence the voice of
their critics so today we have a
president who attacks fake news a lot of
my liberal friends and I am a
bleeding-heart liberal as well as a
civil libertarian but a lot of my
liberal friends will say but there is
such danger coming from right-wing media
and the dark corners of the Internet
shouldn't we censor that version of fake
news and I say who exercises the lever
of powers today are we going to give to
the Trump administration the power to
decide which news is sufficiently fake
sufficiently dangerous sufficiently
harmful that their FCC licenses should
be revoked I think it would not be Fox
News whose license would be revoked or
whose voices would be suppressed it
would be CNN and so forth and and mark
my words I would be equally distraught
at having voices on the on the right
silenced for a whole lot of reasons one
of which is of the indivisibility of all
rights so if we're licensing the
government or empowering the government
say this is sufficiently misleading that
it's going to be suppressed you know it
would just be a matter of time before
there's a change in administration a
change in ideology and it would be
voices on the other end of the political
spectrum that are suppressed and then
also for the reason that censorship does
more harm than good
in general which is that there is some
really important benefit to confront
ideas that are out there that people
hold I want to know that they have those
ideas I don't want them to hide in the
dark corners of the internet and to go
underground I want to be able to respond
to them perhaps dissuade people from
holding those ideas certainly persuade
other people not to adhere to those
ideas if it's a hateful or
discriminatory idea
I want to monitor the people who have
those ideas to make sure that they don't
actually engage in discriminatory or
violent conduct so there are all kinds
of benefits from listening even I would
say especially to ideas that we consider
to be dangerous and an odious the United
States Supreme Court made an observation
which I think is really important that
freedom of speech in terms of government
policies public policies is especially
important because it is not only a
matter of individual liberty and
self-expression but it is essential for
our system of self-government and the
way the Supreme Court put it was more or
less this that freedom of speech about
policy issues is the essence of
self-government the message to the team
is keep the eyes on the prize we have to
look beyond the particular factual
situation and understand that we are
fighting for something larger which
encompasses the ideas that are
antithetical to the ones that happen to
be at issue in a particular case so when
people will often say to me as somebody
who is Jewish and the daughter of a
Holocaust survivor who barely survived
the Buchenwald concentrate
in camp how can i of all people defend
the Nazis and I always say I'm not
defending the Nazis I'm defending
freedom of speech as an inviolable
indivisible principle that is only going
to remain strong if we continue to
respect that bedrock viewpoint
neutrality principle denying government
the power to suppress an idea merely
because in one community that idea is
deemed to be unpopular or hateful or
hate it because I know that in many
communities in this country ideas that I
cherish as a civil libertarian as a
human rights champion those ideas are
seen as dangerous and are subject to
censorship so I'm not defending the
Nazis I'm defending a principle that is
especially important for those of us who
want to have the freedom to raise our
voices to protest the Nazis and
everything they stand for
[Music]